32 meatballs good day
that idiot's been feeding us for a week
we'll never have to buy meatballs again
hey it's snowing
oh my God it's the first snowfall of
Christmas
is that just so magical for you little
girl can you not wait to have a hot
chocolate and cuddle up with Papa and
tell them about all your Christmas
dreams hmm it's not even real snow look
it's dusting
pitiful
hey Dwight
damn it Jim you cannot throw snowballs
in here well it's not a snowball because
it's only a dusting right
look at that there's a pebble in there
you could have killed me oh don't be
such a baby yeah who's a little girl now
you've reached the voicemail of Dwight
Kurt Schrute please leave
[Music]
I have no feeling in my fingers or penis
but I think it was worth it
oh
um I was laying on the ground
defenseless and uh he just kept throwing
him until he exhausted himself and uh
then
how about icing it LOL Dwight
I never formally congratulated you on
your promotion so I'd just like to say
congratulations
wow that's
really thoughtful of you Dwight thank
you you're welcome
I inserted a listening device into the
belly of the mallard now I can observe
Jim trap Jim and Destroy Jim just like
in the Bavarian fairy tale
only this time the mallard skins the
toad alive
and of course in this version you lose
the whole veiled critique of the Kaiser
thing
I'm sorry to have been bugging you all
these years
a real handsome duck Mallard okay I'll
get out of your hair
thank you
[Music]
oh where'd you get that hat
I'd rather not say
foreign
[Music]
38 pound Bond
curves
I've got eight hours of this
of course I wanted Jim to find the
mallard make him feel safe
did you really think I would put my
primary listening device in a wooden
mallard
I'm not insane
oh okay oh
what is this some
a meatball really
it's always more fun to mess with Dwight
with an audience that was usually Pam so
now that she's out I had to find someone
else
turns out that Stanley is quite the
comedy fan
but not everything makes him laugh
he has very specific tastes
through a painstaking process of trial
and error I found out what he likes
and it's really weird Jim come on SO
juvenile
what the you've been meatballed
are you ready for some meatballs oh man
this is not very clever Jim I know look
for your stapler
really Jim really
very funny
okay
what's a hole
32 meatballs good day
that idiot's been feeding us for a week
we'll never have to buy meatballs again
last week Dwight sent out a memo about
the dress code so this is me showing him
that I'm taking it very seriously
get the fish
yes
I really wish you would have told me the
new boss was coming today what no I
don't want to make everybody nervous
nope I mean I could have brought a
change of clothes or you look Dynamite
what are you talking about very slick
okay
I'm Jim Halpert from sales hey just
wanted to say if you need anything let
me know
why are you wearing a tuxedo
I didn't think you noticed
it's funny actually there's a another
salesman out here Dwight Schrute he sent
out this memo as he always does and it
was about professionalism in the
workplace and of course he singled me
out so I just had to mess with him
uh
oh you'd understand it if you read the
memo which I should probably get you
there's probably one in the
drawer uh it was pretty crazy
but uh
not more crazy than wearing a tux at
work I grant you that so I'm gonna uh
your name is Jim Jim helper yep so just
gonna let you get back to it so
oh yeah this will be easy so just like
rearrange the buttons and stuff yeah
yeah like when he presses door closed
the door's open or he presses Lobby it
goes the third floor stuff like that can
you do that yeah let me take a look at
the circus board
Dwight is about to get so Pam
hey did you SMS text message me yeah I
wanted to show you something in the
lobby come on
yeah
okay that's weird it's just hitting door
closed what there we go what
good is this elevator going up
hey the elevator is disobeying us
oh okay okay we are stuck we are stuck
Hank Hank can you hear us
oh my God okay emergency protocol
um just calm down Pam try and pry open
those front doors immediately I don't
use your Talons Prime open okay
god well don't look Frank Dwight what
are you doing we might
we've only two seconds I got 56 ounces
of fluid in my bladder and we have to
establish a p corner
[Music]
zombie
zombie zombie
[Music]
in your hair
[Music]
yes please okay good
tuna
are there any messages nope so weird
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
large tuna have you seen my cell phone
device
my home is someone just calling right
now
there is a call
sorry I annoyed you with my friendship
[Music]
excuse me
and I'm also sorry that a lot of people
here for some reason think it's funny to
steal someone's personal property and
hide it from them
here's a little news flash it's not
funny
in fact it's pretty freaking unfunny